what you think is socially acceptable or
proper or the way that it should be has
absolutely nothing to do with the way
you should be running your business just
because you don't think it's great that
people are in their phone 20 hours a day
or just because when you go out with
your boyfriend - or husband or wife or
spouse - at a dinner and you see a
couple over there and you're like look
how sad that is they're on the phones
the whole time just cuz you believe that
and just because you don't like it and
cuz you're scared that your kids are
watching YouTube for four-and-a-half
hours a day just cuz you don't like that
doesn't mean that that's the way you're
supposed to market your business you're
supposed to flip it understand that's
the reality of the marketplace the
quickest way to go out of business is to
be romantic about how you make your
money and I highly implore all of you to
figure out that it is 2013 if you are
not as an event marketer in full pledge
effort of storytelling on Facebook
Twitter Pinterest and Instagram at this
moment you were borderline not relevant
to what's about to happen in next 24
months that's a period